humans we can be our own worst enemies  we can set ourselves barriers before  Society does because sometimes people  say oh it's my friends my family Society  they say I can't achieve actually I  think we can be we can internalize that  and say actually because of those  influences I shouldn't aim to go to a  good University I shouldn't think about  Oxbridge I shouldn't aim for a  conventional career in the city I  shouldn't try and become a doctor I  almost think that we average the  experiences and motivations of people  around us so if people that you spend  your time with are very negative very  moody have low self-esteem we naturally  average out let's say the five closest  people and we have we take on that sort  of the same trait but if you're around  people that think that the sky is the  limit actually then okay maybe you're  not going to end up having reaching the  sky but you will raise your aspiration  foreign